da hatte man gleich den ganzen eindruck
eva quadbeck ist bei uns vom redaktions
netzwerk deutschland leitet das
hauptstadtbüro jetzt kann man sagen frau
quadbeck dass die entzauberung von
robert habeck eben gange ist irgendwie
vom poster boy zum patzer bei titeln die
kollegen ist nicht insgesamt der zauber
dieser regierung ein wenig
verschwunden also von den friede freude
eierkuchen bildern die man da gerade
gesehen hat schloss meseberg darf man
sich natürlich nicht täuschen lassen es
so dass habe keine groben handwerklichen
fehler gemacht hat mit beckers umlage
und es hat tatsächlich viele bei spd und
fdp ja es war so eine mischung aus
schadenfreude
erleichterung
dass man da gesehen hat da kann man mal
so richtig schön rein gehen
bemerkenswert war das eben es nicht nur
die zweite reihe gemacht hat das macht
man normalerweise also dass man die
zweite reihe wenn der ärger ist
realisieren lässt sich das also
öffentlich kritisieren lässt oder auch
schon mal hinter den kulissen anrufen
und gegenseitig klagen diesmal ist eben
auch der spd chef da nach vorne gegangen
er hat also das ist ja eigentlich auch
die nerven verloren bin ja so was also
wenn er so was sagt und da kann man dann
schon sehen dass es ordentlich ruckelnd
in dieser koalition
ich gehe aber trotzdem davon aus dass am
wochenende die vernunft siegt und man
ein entlastungspaket zusammenzimmern
wird und in meseberg war es dann
tatsächlich so dass man auch wieder
pfleglich miteinander umgegangen ist und
diese drei parteichefs untereinander
haben das ja auch vermieden ja sich
sozusagen die regeln das dann
tatsächlich untereinander und
dementsprechend war dann auch die
botschaft von meseberg wir haben uns
wieder vertragen aber
eigentlich wäre meseberg ja wirklich der
zeitpunkt gewesen zudem so ein
entlastungspaket vorliegen und sie denkt
in diesem sinne weil
heute müssen ja alle irgendwie wieder
mehr zahlen an den tankstellen und die
bahnfahrer mussten jetzt ihr neues
monats ticket kaufen nicht wissen ob es
ein anschluss ticket gibt ja nein also
investiere ich dann noch mal richtig in
meinem monatsticket das wissen die leute
alle nicht dass die koalition kommt zu
spät mit diesem entlassen paket das ist
schon mal einen befund ricarda lang ist
bei uns eine der zwei vorsitzenden der
grünen frau lang jetzt ist ja irgendwie
so viel darum freude vermittelt worden
durch olaf scholz dass man noch nicht so
richtig weiß was in diesem entlastungs
paket drin steht wäre es wichtiger
geworden ohne die fdp
wir sind in einer koalition unsere
aufgabe ist in dieser koalition ein
gutes paket auf dem weg zu bringen und
dass wir es können innerhalb der ampel
das haben wir bereits zweimal bewiesen
dass er mit einem ersten
entlastungspaket bewiesen zum beispiel
kinder sofort zuschlag für familien mit
kindern in armut das haben wir den
zweiten entlastungsschritt bereits zum
beispiel ein euro ticket und ich kann
ein bisschen nachvollziehen das glaube
ich dieser eindruck entsteht von ihr
wollte doch alles anders machen diese
koalition ihr wolltet auch anders
miteinander umgehen und dass wir das
nicht so gut hinbekommen haben letzten
wochen das muss man glaube ich einmal
ziemlich ehrlich anerkennt wie weiland
sie jetzt am wochenende könnte es eben
dieses dritte entlastungs paket geben
wie weit sind sie und wie präzise kann
also wie sehr kann der bürger darauf
hoffen dass es diesen dieses anschluss
paket geben wir werden diese woche ein
drittes entlastungs paket beschließen
heute ist dass lara also bis sonntag und
das verlangen auch die bürgerinnen von
uns denn wir waren ja nicht dass wir uns
untereinander verkabeln sondern dass wir
jetzt liefern und dass wir antworten auf
diese soziale krise liefern und das
werden wir tun ich kann ja mal sagen was
für mich wichtig ist was sein
entlastungspaket drin sein muss erstens
wir brauchen direktzahlungen jetzt noch
in diesem jahr für den herbst und winter
die prices schnellen ja gerade die höhe
ich finde es am besten wir machen eine
energiepreis pauschale die sozial
gestaffelt ist natürlich vor allem die
menschen im blick nehmen die wenig geld
habe ich schon mal ich würde sagen die
zwei sachen merken wir uns jetzt man
wäre ja noch angehen dann einen noch
dann darf noch die zweite brauchen wir
eine anschlussregelung für ein euro
ticket das war ein schöner erfolg für
klima und soziales damals mit ihrer
angenehmen klima also zehn prozent der
autofahrten sind nicht gemacht worden
aber dafür umso mehr fahrten also ich
glaube das war eher eine soziale
maßnahme als eine klima maßnahme dass
ich es egal dass wir natürlich
langfristig das nicht leute erst mal
alle verhaltensweisen umstellen wegen
drei monaten darf ist klar aber wir
haben gesehen es gibt ein potenzial zum
umsteigen und dass wir jetzt daran
anknüpfende langfristigen variante und
erstmal ist ja auch der punkt dass
menschen mehr mobilität haben gerade
menschen mit wenig geld menschen die
sich das sonst nicht leisten kann das
ist ein wahnsinniges soziale zu gewinnen
das ist auch ein freiheitsgewinn so da
ist die offene frage an christian dürr
den fraktionsvorsitzenden der fdp den
wir aus bremen bei uns in der sendung
begrüßen hat der erste frage sie dürfen
gerne kurze antworten in welcher form
werde die fdp unter tätiger mithilfe von
herrn bissingen denn ein nachfolger für
das neue euro ticket erfinden ja das
tolle am 9 euro ticket war ja das ist
unkompliziert war wir hatten
wahrscheinlich in den letzten drei
monaten das unkomplizierteste öpnv
ticket in europa und daran gilt es
anzuknüpfen also das heißt quasi in
berlin was buchen kann und münchen damit
fahren kann das ist dauerhaft nicht neun
euro sein kann das ist glaube ich jedem
bewusst dass würden dann die
steuerzahlerinnen steuerzahler alles
tragen das müssten an anderer stelle
kürzen das will niemand aber die idee
die dahinter steckt diese technische
idee diese digitale idee die ist super
und insofern schauen wir den anschluss
hinter sich
heute sagen gehen wir zudem die man das
letzte mal vergessen hat nämlich zu den
rentnern dass man bei den rentnern
nachlegen muss das haben sie im juli
noch für unnötig gehalten und für
unmöglich haben sie rechtzeitig haben
die liberalen rechtzeitig ihr
mitfühlendes herz entdeckt ja da muss
man ganz kurz noch mal an das erste und
zweite entlastungspaket zurückgehen
ricaner lang sprach dass gerade an das
war damals schon ein wuchtiger aufschlag
sucht übrigens seinesgleichen europa und
es war gut dass wir es schon früher
gemacht haben damals war es der wunsch
der spd eine sogenannte energie
pauschale zu machen an die arbeitnehmer
da waren die rentner nicht mit dabei und
jetzt muss man darüber reden inwiefern
man rentner studierende beispielsweise
eben auch einmalig mit entlasten kann
und ich füge hinzu frau illner natürlich
auch die 48 millionen einkommen
steuerzahlerin einkommensteuerzahler
denn die dürfen wir hier in der debatte
auch nicht vergessen sie sind auch voll
von den hohen energiepreisen betroffen
und genau über die reden wir jetzt und
sagen allein am beispiel der gaspreise
die explodierten gab es enorme
veränderungen preissteigerungen für die
bürger gaspreise
gaspreise schießen in die höhe vor einem
jahr musste ein singlehaushalt 430 euro
bezahlen ab oktober sind es 1073 bei
einem zweipersonenhaushalt
verdreifacht sich die gasrechnung im
selben zeitraum auf
2463 euro jährlich
dreimal so viel zeit ab oktober auch
eine vierköpfige familie
3633 euro
hier ist meine frage 40 prozent der
deutschen haushalte haben kein erspartes
um allein diesen gaspreis schock
abzuwenden oder zu bezahlen wer kümmert
sich um die das was sie gerade im
einspieler gezeigt haben ist ja der
hintergrund der hohen inflation in
deutschland in ganz europa und deswegen
sagen wir ja beisteuern müssen mal
ansetzen da entlasten wir die menschen
nicht ganz direkt indem sie weniger
steuern zahlen es wäre unfair wenn die
einkommen weniger wert sind aber
gleichzeitig noch trotzdem hohe steuern
anfallen deswegen dieser idee des
inflationsausgleichs im steuersystem es
kommt direkt bei den menschen an und das
wäre
nein das ist nicht der fall im gegenteil
der vorschlag von christian hinten ist
ja nach oben gedeckelt beim etwa
anderthalbfachen des
durchschnittsverdienstes also da geht es
hier nicht um reiche leute sind heute
haben keinen erspartes aber sie hat ihn
kommende
3600 als familie zusätzlich zu zahlen
deswegen dreizehntes monatsgehalt ring
deswegen genau deswegen wollen wir ja an
den direkten mechanismus drei nämlich
bei der steuer da kann man direkt
entlasten wir können vor allem sicher
sein dass das geld bei den menschen
wirklich verbleibt deswegen ist das aus
meiner sicht ein guter vorschlag auch
darüber reden werden wir reden in den
kommenden tagen wie bei anderen auch
möglicherweise einmalzahlung aber ich
will noch mal betonen es geht eben darum
dass die menschen wirklich direkt
entlastet werden und das lassen sie mich
noch hinzufügen wir reden ja in den
kommenden wochen auch über eine
wohngeldreform also diejenigen hatte ja
nicht transferempfänger sind genau aber
die gleichzeitig auch gleichzeitig keine
hohen einkommen haben also die
dazwischen sozusagen sind mit kleinen
und kleinsten kommen die kann man auch
über das wohngeld entlasten also die
welt noch an diese menschen denken wir
die sie an beschildert die
einmalzahlungen werden wir noch reden da
gibt es überlegungen die tatsächlich
auch so zu gestalten dass sie nicht
besteuert werden müssten und den
menschen eben sofort und in aller höhe
helfen karl laumann ist unbedingt zu
begrüßen er ist der arbeit und
sozialminister von nordrhein-westfalen
und uns heute abend aus düsseldorf
zugeschaltet herr laumann sie dürfen mit
uns gemeinsam noch mal ganz kurz
friedrich merz zu hören den haben wir
selten erregt erlebt
was soll das eigentlich dass wir hier
für 42 millionen menschen 300 euro
pauschal bezahlen ich hätte es mir
gewünscht dass nicht 300 euro für alle
sondern 1000 euro für diejenigen die es
am bittersten nötig haben aus
öffentlichen kassen bezahlt werden
nicht 300 euro für 42 millionen sondern
1000 für die die es bitter nötig haben
wie viele von diesen 42 millionen
sollten ihrer meinung nach 1000 euro
bekommen ja gut also ich finde wir
müssen einfach mal darüber reden wenn
wir über die unteren einkommen reden
mittlerer einkommen reden überwiegen
reden wir das mittlere das mittlere
einkommen liegt bei uns in
nordrhein-westfalen ich glaube wo sich
die zahlen auch in deutschland war
3566 euro also wenn ein handwerker
3566 euro verdienen stunde und zwanzig
euro wir sagen in der sozialforschung
seit vielen jahren da gibt es auch
keinen streit wer ein drittel unter
diesem durchschnitt liegt das sind
2.466 euro der is armutsgefährdet das
sind leute die ein stunden und von 14
euro haben das sind aber menschen die
nicht den transferleistungen sind und
diese menschen die jetzt so gerade um
die runden kommen da sind in
nordrhein-westfalen immer in 850.000 ja
die kommen nicht klar und die sind bei
den ersten und zweiten entlastungspaket
wo 30 milliarden jahr ausgegeben worden
sind hat man für die schlicht und
ergreifend zu wenig getan dass man die
rentner außen vor lässt ich glaube die
das gemacht haben wissen gar nicht wo
die durchschnittsrenten sind die liga
ist wobei 1500 euro bei uns in
deutschland nach 45 beschäftigungsjahre
und da hätte ich schon von einer
regierung erwarte dass man die leute die
fleißig sind die gerade über die runden
kommen dass man die bei den entlastungen
mehr berücksichtigt hätte wenn man als
regierung sagt wir wollen die
schuldenbremse einhalten wofür ich bin
dann hat man nur eine begrenzte menge
geld auch in der krise und ich finde da
muss man das geld an diejenigen geben
die sonst nicht mehr klarkommen ich
meine der steuerentlastung ich mich ja
gar nicht dagegen aber muss natürlich
sehen dass man die menschen wo ich jetzt
darüber gesprochen habe bei der
einstellung wird zum beispiel der kalten
progression ein ganz klein bisschen
entlastet die großen entlastungen gehen
in die durchschnittseinkommen und in die
überdurchschnittlichen einkommen und ich
finde und daran muss man jetzt auch das
neue entlastungspaket messen kommt es
wirklich bei den leuten an die auf der
einen seite nicht unbedingt in
transferleistungen sind aber auf der
anderen seite jeden euro umdrehen müssen
und mit der familie über die runden zu
kommen und diese menschen werden die
rücklagen nicht haben und sie werden
auch die nachzahlungen die sie durch das
heizen bekommen die die durch die
energie bekommen nicht finanzieren
können und das ist ja nicht nur der gast
also der mensch der mit gas heizt wir
haben ja genau eine ähnliche explosion
bei den ölpreisen oder auch bei pellets
und ähnlichen kanäle was es an
alternativen quellen gibt auch schon
diskutiert und fragen design neubauer
klimaschutz aktivistin von freitag
futures sie von neubauer sagen keine
halben sachen machen frieden kriegt man
nicht umsonst und klimaschutz kriegt man
auch nicht umsonst das sind gute sätze
wenn trotzdem menschen in diesem land
sagen dass sie diese beiden rechnungen
nicht mehr bezahlen können was denken
sie denn
es geht um die nebenkostenabrechnung zum
beispiel ja das ist gravierend also ich
glaube wir alle kennen menschen nicht
geht und das thema ich auch dazu also
die meisten menschen fragen sich gerade
was kommt da auf uns zu dass es super
beunruhigend zu wissen wir können uns
nicht darauf verlassen dass wir im
endeffekt geschützt werden zum beispiel
vom staat
und wir sind in einer situation in der
in der nicht absehbar ist was da noch
kommen was ist die nächste krise wie
entwickelt sich das bei all dem aber
über die entlastung über die man
sprechen muss frage ich mich manchmal
momente wo ist dann der augenblick an
dem man sich fragt warum sind werden
diese energie krise also warum sind denn
die rechnung so hoch warum ist das denn
so eskaliert wie es eskalieren konnte
warum sind wir da reingerutscht weil wir
ein katastrophales missmanagement
missmanagement erlebt haben in der
energiepolitik in den letzten
jahrzehnten und das war diese
abhängigkeit von kohle öl und gas von
autokraten wie putin und da sei wir
haben jetzt und last so sehnlich
lediglich wir haben zu wenig energie wir
haben die falsche energie
und sie sind sie glauben daran dass
diese regierung jetzt tatsächlich auch
zu übergangslösungen kommen und sie
finden muss um die menschen auf der
einen seite zu entlassen und auf der
anderen seite dafür zu sorgen dass der
staat nicht leute die ich frage mich wo
die regierung ist die sagt wir
versprechen euch dass der letzte winter
in dem es so hart wird weil wir
wegkommen von den fossilen energien so
schnell wie es geht das geht nicht alles
sofort aber viel kann man sehr schnell
machen wenn man in lichtgeschwindigkeit
neuerdings lng terminals aufbauen kann
dann kann man auch in
lichtgeschwindigkeit erneuerbare
aufbauen das muss doch die große
botschaft sein dass das ganze als
notfallmaßnahme auch ein als notfall
behandelt wird und man parallel jetzt
alles darauf gibt dass wir aus dieser
energie krise raus sein neues rauskommen
und dem kirchenchor ium herauskommen
glauben sie dass die menschen das besser
verstehen wenn sich manche aktivisten
auf straßen kleben ich glaube die
aktivisten ihr straßen blieben nach
diesem sommer an dem wir wirklich
überall erlebt haben was es heißt in
einer klimakatastrophe zu sein während
30 prozent von pakistan zum beispiel von
fluten bedroht sind dass es bleibt eine
eigene legitimation ich glaube wir
würden uns allen gefallen tun damit
aufzuhören das ende des monats gegen das
ende vom jahrzehnt auszuspielen die
meisten menschen sind nicht nur menschen
die nebenkosten bezahlen ist noch eltern
die am sorgen um ihre kinder sind
menschen die gerade erleben wie uns das
klima um die ohren fliegen und ist es
glaube ich an der zeit dass wir
respektieren dass diese sorgen
zusammentreffen und das schöne ist ja es
gibt lösungen dass man euro ticket ist
natürlich ein phänomenales beispiel
dafür es gibt lösungen die man heute
menschen entlastet und gleichzeitig
darauf hinwirkt dass wir rauskommen aus
diesen energiekrisen rauskommen aus der
klimakrise rauskam auch diesen
anhaltenden not ständen die uns hier
alle so belasten da ist frau lang das
leben in natürlich immer konkret
widerwärtig und gemeinden weil wir jetzt
in einer ganz anderen situation sind und
gleichzeitig in der in der wir aus ganz
viel raus wollen wie sehr denken sie
braucht man in einer solchen phase den
hinweis dass auch der waschlappen eine
gute erfindung ist wie sehr hilft es den
bürgern vor allen dingen die die eben
drehen wenn ich in den oder dezent
korrekter weise in der tasche umdrehen
müssen es ist komplett klar dass werte
über einsparungen reden müssen das über
einsparungen reden müssen das über
einsparungen insgesamt reden müssen ich
glaube dass wir uns einen größeren
gefallen tun das nicht über individuelle
tipps zu tun sondern indem wir auf
politische lösungen vorlegen die gibt es
ja durchaus ich würde gern noch mal auf
einen punkt eingehen er grad auf
gekommen ist weil sie ja gesagt haben
der preis für klima schützen können die
leute die jetzt noch zahlen das was wir
gerade erleben diese hohen preise die
liegen nicht am klimaschutz sonst total
am gegenteil weil der vergangenheit zu
wenig klimaschutz gemacht wurde weil die
erneuerbaren energien nicht ausgebaut
wurden deshalb haben wir uns diese
situation die abhängigkeit von den
fossilen ist nicht nur ein
sicherheitspolitisches risiko
soziales risiko sie hören was sie hören
wollten frau lang sie hätten auch den
satz auf schnappen können zu sagen jetzt
wird in einer unglaublichen
geschwindigkeit ein lng terminal nach
dem anderen an gemietet oder gekauft
durch diese bundesregierung also
flüssiggas man könnte in der gleichen
atemberaubenden geschwindigkeit sich auf
die erneuerbaren weiter werfen aber
genau das müssen wir jetzt gerade tun
und er ist wenn man sich das oster paket
anschaut ist das ja genau der ansatz
also sagen wir müssen jetzt einzelne
schwierige entscheidung treffen zum
beispiel entschied und im oster paket
haben wir das tempo für den ausbau
erneuerbaren energien verdreifacht eine
wahnsinnige planungs beschleuniger auf
den weg gebracht wird ist ja viel zu
langsam sind wir haben endlich das zwei
prozent ziel festgelegt als zwei prozent
der ganzen fläche für erneuerbare
energien für windkraft genutzt werden
müssen das heißt wir werden in diesem
winter schwierige entscheidungen treffen
aber der weg zur unabhängigkeit das in
die erneuerbaren energien und dafür
brauchen wir jetzt volle geschwindigkeit
glauben sie den gründe naja das problem
ist ja öfter einen seite dass das
natürlich nicht ausreicht und da gibt es
länder die die experten ich habe mit
claudia kempfert gesprochen wir sagen
dass liegen maße auf den tisch wie zum
beispiel solaranlagen die gerade nicht
die aufgebaut und aber nicht ans netz
angeschlossen sind einfach weil
zertifikate fehlen also man könnte noch
deutlich schneller deutlich bewusst
eingehen und die frage ist sie aber auch
was wird sonst noch gemacht also es wird
ein bisschen erneuerbar ausgebaut und
das ist durchaus schneller als das mal
war gleichzeitig wird in anderen
ministerien arbeitsverweigerung
betrieben also wir nehmen zum beispiel
das verkehrsministerium was ich offensiv
weigert klimaschutz ziele einzuhalten
klima pläne vorzulegen das ist so
gravierend wasser völker bisschen gerade
produziert es wäre in jedem anderen
berufsfeld ein kündigungsgrund er denkt
vielleicht da kommt damit durch weil man
jetzt so ein bisschen 9 euro ticket
rhetorik von christian lindner hört aber
das funktioniert nicht das heißt selbst
wenn teile der regierung los legen und
sagen wir machen was wird das
kontinuierlich unterwandert von anderen
teilen der regierung die das offensiv
boykottieren und da muss man sich auch
als grüne partei fragen wie weit können
wir da kompromisse machen war schützen
wir gerade das koalitionsklima oder das
weltklima und damit sind wir automatisch
bei christian dürr und sagen stichwort
arbeitsverweigerung durch den minister
nein jetzt müssen wir ganz kurz mal die
dinge sortieren das eine ist das was wir
gerade besprochen haben mich was wir tun
wollen entlastungen da bin ich übrigens
interessant gerade was ich hörte von
erlauben dass eine absage an die kalte
progression gemacht hat weil er gesagt
hat schuldenbremse einhalten aber nun
sollten wir uns konzentrieren
auch bestimmte gruppen nur da bin ich
sehr dagegen ich halte sehr viel davon
auch die breite mitte der gesellschaft
zunächst dass das rein an das andere und
da war ich bei dem durchaus bei der
ersten wortmeldung von frau neubauer
sehr dabei wir müssen an den preis an
das ja die ursache für das was die
privaten haushalte stemmen müssen dieser
tage und die unternehmen in deutschland
wir müssen ganz dringend und sehr
kurzfristig an den preis wann denn diese
hohen strompreise insbesondere kann kein
unternehmen in deutschland und kein
privater haushalt sich leisten das muss
man so deutlich sagen deswegen ja auch
unser vorschlag die menge auszuweiten
das wäre ein punkt den wir einer
koalition noch besprechen müssen
stichwort
laufzeitverlängerung der kernkraftwerke
aber zum verkehrsministerium
verkehrsministerium ehrlich ein
er hat ja ja der hat ja deswegen hätte
ich sonst noch einmal erwähnt der der
hat ja gerade im rahmen von klimaschutz
einiges vorgelegt übrigens auch da
müssen wir ein bisschen kreativer werden
an der stelle wie wäre es denn wenn
unsere vielen millionen pkws in
deutschland co2 neutral auch als
verbrennungsmotoren fahren können
sollten wir uns in europa fare einsetzen
stichwort klimaneutrale kraftstoffe also
ein bisschen innovativer denken nicht
immer nur auf eine technologie setzen
das ist ja das was volker wissing
vorschlägt ich würde mich freuen wenn
wir die 46 millionen pkws die wir
zurzeit noch als verbrenner haben in
wenigen jahren schon komplett
klimaneutral betreiben könnten das sind
innovative punkt und darauf setzen wir
insofern teile ich da die kritik von
neubau um das einmal anders zu halten
und hier ein bisschen die perspektive
auf zu machen es gibt ein expertenrat
der bundesregierung der guckt sich an
was machen die ministerien dieser
expertenrat hat geprüft was legt volker
wissing vor um die klimaziele
einzuhalten die haben die prüfung
abgebrochen weil sie festgestellt haben
ist gab da nichts zu prüfen man hätte
über 260 millionen tonnen co2 einsparen
müssen die so genau und diese noten 14
mit pläne für 14 millionen vorgelegt
also um es ins verhältnis zu legen
volker wissing klimaschutz ambitionen
reichen gerade so weit wie man einsparen
würde wenn man acht jahren tempolimit
hatte selbst das möchte man nicht das
wäre entspricht auch der größe von drei
jahren ein euro ticket auch das möchte
man nicht also was da an boykott
wirklich stattfindet von
klimaschutzmaßnahmen die ja auch immer
eine mobilität steigernde wirkung haben
oder am besten fall eben auch eine
befreiende wirkung für menschen über all
das ist komplett absurd und wie gesagt
das stellt nicht nur die fdp in frage
sondern eben die gesamte koalition der
ist ja anscheinend gerade aktuell
beträgt
da muss ich mal widersprechen frau immer
ganz kurz das er war das ja so nicht
stimmt also erstens mal ist was
vorgelegt wurden von allen ressorts dass
das eine und das zweite ist natürlich
kann ich
natürlich hat volker wissing da auch
eine hypothek geerbt seiner csu
vorgänger war im verkehrsbereich das
teil um ein kleines erinnern analysiert
naja es ist ja wir sind ja sechs monate
in dieser koalition das für den
kompletten verkehrsbereich noch nicht
co2 neutral haben bedauere ich auch aber
ich habe ja gerade hat vorgeschlagen wie
man das machen darüber reden wir auch
gerade in der ampel insofern haben wir
da sehr konkrete vorschläge und auch
mein wunsch ist es dass wir den
verkehrssektor co2 neutral bekommen ohne
aber die individuelle mobilität ich
komme aus dem ländlichen raum in
niedersachsen zu verbieten wir sind noch
mal herr laumann bei der frage
wahrscheinlich sind sie froh dass sie
gerade nicht mehr mit der fdp regieren
oder
bei der frage was sie glauben dass diese
sparappelle bringen wie hilfreich ist es
wenn politiker sagen wie wenig sie
duschen und rest der waschlappen eine
gute erfindung ist wie lange duschen sie
also ich glaube erst einmal dass diese
diese ratschläge wie lange man duschen
soll und so von politikern überhaupt
nichts bringen die situation ist doch
ganz klar wenn energie so teuer ist wie
sie jetzt ist werden alle menschen
insbesondere die auf ihren geldbeutel
achten müssen sich dreimal überlegen was
sie tun und sie werden alle überlegen
und in die richtung an stellen wie kann
ich energie sparen dass ich dann auch
für das wichtige letzten endes die
energie bezahlinhalte ihnen nicht
unterstellen dass sie gedankenlos mit
energie umgehen wie sehr ich sehe auch
ich sehe auch im verhalten in der
öffentlichkeit auch wenn ich einmal
ministerium denke wo ja auch 600 leute
arbeiten
es wird vielmehr darauf geachtet dass
das licht ausgemacht wird dass die leute
sagen also jetzt im sommer heizen die ja
nicht aber es ist merkwürdig die
menschen gucken sehr darauf wissen
worauf es ankommt
sie wollen sparen sie wissen auch was
für eine lage wie haben und ich will es
mal so sagen wir haben jetzt eine
situation die ja auch deswegen so ist
war wie krieg in europa haben und ich
finde wir müssen jetzt erst mal dafür
sorgen dass wir in dieser gesellschaft
so durch diese zeit kommen dass der
plattform putin nicht aufgeht dass die
gesellschaft sich in deutschland spaltet
und wir soziale unruhen kriegen und
deswegen finde ich muss man geld in die
hand nehmen genau um dieses zu
verhindern und das bewegt mich als
sozialminister in nordrhein westfalen
weil ich sehe dass diese
nachzahlung und diese gasrechnungen aber
überhaupt die ganze energie rechnung die
die haushalte bekommen von einem noch
größeren teil der bevölkerung
nicht bezahlt werden können und sie sind
bei den 30 milliarden die ausgegeben
worden sind dabei bleibe ich nicht
genügend im augen gelassen du hast kann
man jetzt ja war im dritten paket ändern
aber dann wird man auch wiederum nicht
mehr für alle geld haben putin will doch
dass wir probleme in unserer eigenen
gesellschaft kriegen und deswegen finde
ich müssen wir hier auch sozialpolitisch
höllisch aufpassen auch bis hin zu der
frage wie gehen wir mit der
energieintensiven industrie in
deutschland um in nordrhein westfalen um
da haben wir gut bezahlte arbeitsplätze
ich sehe das auch als eine präventive
sozialpolitik an dass wir diese
industriezweige diese krise bringen der
sind frau kurt beck noch mal bei der
vielleicht ein bisschen ordnenden frage
wird nicht jedes entlastungspaket dass
diese ampel regierung jetzt auf den
tisch legt in den augen vielleicht der
mehrheit sogar dieser bürger zu wenig
sein ja so was klar ist dass man ohnehin
nicht für alle alles ausgleichen kann
was im moment an schäden an defiziten
entsteht das ist ganz klar und das ist
auch richtig man das geht da gibt es ja
ein konsens darüber dass man vor allen
dingen erst mal den leuten helfen
mussten das wasser bis zum hals steht
und da kann man vielleicht den helfen
denen das wasser nur bis zu den knien
steht also es ist ja so dass auch
durchaus leute mit guten und mittleren
einkommen schreck kriegen wenn sie ihre
gasrechnungen sehen wenn sie ihre neuen
abschläge sehen wenn sie sehen dass sie
für das gleiche zeugs was sie im
supermarkt kaufen inzwischen das
doppelte bezahlen müssen also das ist ja
das zieht sich ja über alle
lebensbereiche und deshalb ist es auch
so wichtig dass der nächste schuss
tempel koalition wirklich sitzt also
dass das paket was am wochenende
geschnürt werden soll das muss
tatsächlich
eine zweistellige dicke milliarden summe
enthalten
es war ja schon mal zu hören dass es
vielleicht zehn milliarden in diesem
jahr sein könnten und dann noch mal 20
bis 30 milliarden im nächsten jahr und
das was zuerst kommt das muss schnell
kommen also das müssen die rückzahlungen
geheim oder gestern wäre gut gewesen
genau ist der erste september wäre gut
gewesen also und man hätte es eine woche
vorher wissen müssen damit man eben auch
über dinge wie 9 euro ticket oder
fortsetzung bescheid weiß und
dann müssten im nächsten jahr müssen so
die substantiellen maßnahmen kommen die
auch im koalitionsvertrag drin stehen so
was wie wohngeld
bürgergeld und damit trifft man ja dann
auch die richtigen schön wäre es
natürlich das ist übrigens interessant
da wird sich die ampel koalition auch
noch mit den ländern einigen müssen weil
sowohl beim wohngeld bei der kalten
progression wie auch bei einem wie auch
immer gearteten ticket für die länder
mit zahlen also das ist auch nicht so
ganz trivial und deshalb müssen am
anfang die zahlungen kommen und dann
müssen die geschichte gekommen wo man
erstmal noch mit den ländern reden muss
und dann wäre es natürlich schön wenn
man auch noch ein signal für das klima
setzen könnte bei dem geld das man
ausschüttet da war ja mal im gespräch
dass man vielleicht den haushalten einen
bestimmten gasbedarf energiebedarf pro
kopf oder pro haushalt wie auch immer
zugesteht und dann sagt was ihr ein
spart das wird für euch dann einfach
günstiger und die leute hätten eine
garantie dass sie eine bestimmte menge
an energie zu einem bestimmten verfahren
tragen und nicht das ist ja moment das
große problem dass alle die sorge haben
dass das durch die decke geht und das
ist ja auch das was die gesellschaft so
pro pfund verunsichert und wenn man noch
mal zurück schaut in die finanzkrise zu
beginn des jahrhunderts
da haben sich ja damals waren es merkel
und steinbrück hingestellt und gesagt
die spareinlagen sind sicher und das war
einfach so eine botschaft die die
gesellschaft beruhigt hat und ich sehe
im moment noch nicht dass die ampel in
der lage ist eine solche botschaft zu
senden aber eigentlich müsste mit diesem
paket am wochenende genauso eine
botschaft kommen und sie müsste
tatsächlich dann auch von dem
bundesfinanzminister kommen der sich in
meseberg und das wird jetzt noch mal
interessant vor allen dingen auch über
die steigenden strompreise
sehr öffentlich geärgert hat auch in der
letzten sendung unserer letzten sendung
war er zu gast und monierte dass nicht
nur die gaspreise durch die geld- decke
gehen sondern auch die strompreise
steigen
und da gibt es einen mechanismus der das
erklärt und wir versuchen jetzt mal
diesen mechanismus zu erklären ich bin
mir sicher sie verstehen was wir sagen
wollen
strom könnte so günstig sein wenn es die
regel zur preisbildung nicht gebe der
strombedarf wird zunächst von den
billigen anbietern bedient erneuerbare
mit rohstoffen zum nulltarif oder die
relativ günstige atomkraft endlagerung
ausgeklammert
kohlekraftwerke sind zwar klimapolitisch
dreckschleudern aber ebenfalls billig
bereich dieses stromangebot aber nicht
muss sehr teurer strom zb aus
gaskraftwerken zusätzlich produziert
werden auch wenn der nur rund zehn
prozent unseres stroms aus macht
bestimmt er dann den preis für die
restlichen 90 prozent so wird aus
günstiger windkraft teurer strom für
verbraucher ab
und in brüssel begrüße ich die
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen guten abend nach brüssel guten
anfang es gibt einen akuten bedarf an
gas und strom und beides geht durch die
decke in den preisen sie wollen raus aus
dieser kopplung sie wollen verhindern
dass gas automatisch genau so teuer ist
wie der strom respektive der strom so
teuer wie das gas ja wie wollen sie das
schaffen wir wollen mit einem
notfallinstrument direkt eingreifen in
den strommarkt und zwar den
überbordenden einfluss des gases des
teuren gases auf die strompreisbildung
reduzieren wir wollen bei den anderen
energieformen dafür sorgen dass die
tatsache dass sie billiger und günstiger
produziert werden tatsächlich auch bei
den verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern
ankommen das heißt ein teil der gewinne
mit denen die
stromerzeuger niemals gerechnet haben
werden wir abschöpfen und dazu nehmen
dass sie vor allen dingen für
einkommensschwache haushalte und
unternehmen zur verfügung gestellt
werden also abzupuffern den strompreis
ist es ist aber selbstverständlich
dass die stromerzeuger der fossilen
energie in der schmutzigen energie auch
ihren krisen beitrag leisten müssen noch
mal nachgefragt wie kann diese
entkopplung funktionieren robert habeck
hat schon mal gesagt das geht nicht auf
einen finger da braucht man auch die
zustimmung der 27 anderen europäischen
staaten ja selbstverständlich machen wir
das in enger zusammenarbeit mit den 27
mitgliedstaaten
ich bin jetzt seit tagen und wir
arbeiten seit wochen daran mit den
verschiedenen mitgliedsländern und den
expertinnen und experten die es dort
auch gibt in verbindung dass wir das
gemeinsam auf den weg bringen aber die
gesetzliche grundlage die regelung die
erarbeitet jetzt die kommission und wird
dann mit einem vorschlag kommen wir
werden wahrscheinlich in zwei schritten
gehen nämlich dass wir am ende der
nächsten woche beim energieminister
treffen die vorschläge von allen seiten
beleuchten und betrachten und bearbeiten
und dann mit einem gesetzesvorschlag
kommen so dass wir relativ schnell dann
auch aktiv werden und wie stellen sie
sich das konkret vor also diese
unverdienten über gewinne die dann
beispielsweise
erneuerbare also ökostrom aber auch
kohle und atomkraftwerke machen die
sollen ab einem bestimmten punkt
abgeschöpft werden aber auf gar keinen
fall eine steuer sein damit man nicht in
juristischen schwierigkeiten kommen dass
eine steuer ist etwas langfristiges
mittel und langfristiges dies hier ist
ein krisen element das man in einer
situation kurzfristig einsetzen kann und
ich glaube wir gehen jetzt nicht in eine
juristische detail diskussion aber die
tatsache dass wir die rechtliche
grundlage dazu haben für krisen momente
bestimmte instrumente zu entwickeln die
nutzen wir genau das was wir vorschlagen
nämlich dass diese über gewinne diese im
grunde unverdienten über gewinne die man
an der strombörse jetzt mitnimmt
verteilt werden abgeschöpft werden um
sie als entlastung den verbrauchern
zurückzugeben wie soll das organisiert
werden und warum haben sie doch eine
zeit gebraucht er sieht diesen
gedankengut folgen
naja die der strommarkt ist über 20
jahre gewachsen und den kann man nicht
so von heute auf morgen ändern deshalb
ist das auch ein notfallinstrument was
wir jetzt
einleiten werden und wir werden die
grundsätzliche reform des strommarktes
ab nächsten jahr beginnen weil das muss
in aller ruhe und ausführlich
vorbereitet werden und die erneuerbaren
dass sie gewinne haben ist uns wichtig
denn es soll reinvestiert werden nur die
gewinne die jetzt durch die decke
schießen mit den niemand jemals
gerechnet hat und sie gar nicht
reinvestiert werden können die wollen
wir abschöpfen und nochmal ich
wiederhole es die fossilen
stromerzeugung also kohle öl und gas die
müssen auch ihren krisen beitrag leisten
damit wir gezielt die
einkommensschwachen haushalte und
unternehmen unterstützen und nochmal sie
möchten diese gewinne nicht unterbinden
sondern sie möchten sie abschöpfen und
verteilt das ist korrekt ja denn es muss
eines auch wichtig sein ich habe ganz am
anfang gesagt es gibt zu wenig energie
insgesamt und wir müssen energie sparen
das heißt das preissignal das energie
insgesamt nicht unendlich zur verfügung
steht und man nicht nachlässig damit
umgehen kann sondern dass es eine knappe
ressource ist und wir sehr gezielt damit
umgehen müssen und sparen müssen das ist
wichtig das preissignal manche haushalte
können sich das gut leisten andere nicht
die müssen wir unterstützen
aber uns ist ja wichtig dass wir
insgesamt rauskommen aus den fossilen
brennstoffen und viel stärker
investieren und auf die dauer
ausschließlich in die erneuerbaren
energien kommen also diesen übergang
einerseits energie sparen und
andererseits investieren in die
transformation für erneuerbaren grüne
saubere energien das ist uns wichtig
frage zu den gasspeichern die sagten die
sind schneller folge worden zu unserer
überraschung als wir dachten nun meldet
sich die industrie und sagt sie sind
auch deshalb schneller gefüllt weil die
produktion drosseln um nicht zu sagen
auch einstellen ist das in ihren oberen
wirklich eine vollständig gute nachricht
es ist eine wichtige nachricht dass die
entschuldung dass die gasspeicher
gefüllt sind
denn wir müssen jeden tag damit rechnen
dass putin vollständig das gas
abgestellt und dann müssen wir reserven
haben von denen die benutzen können wir
haben mit unserem regionalgruppen die
dafür sorgen dass der gast fluss in den
verschiedenen regionen europas
gleichmäßig bleibt und das gas dahin
fließt wo es am meisten gebraucht wird
auch besprochen dass es wichtig ist
bestimmte industrien zu drosseln damit
wir diese einsparungen auch machen
können das ist ein ganz fein
abgestimmtes sehr komplexes
szenario das entwickelt worden ist wir
bereiten uns ja die ganze zeit wären wir
diese krise bearbeiten immer auf den
schlimmsten fall auch vor so dass wir
genau wissen wie wir gestuft bestimmte
produktionen gegebenenfalls drosseln
können das ziel ist dass wir durch
diesen winter kommen das ziel ist dass
putin uns nicht länger erpressen kann
mit seinen fossilen brennstoffen das
ziel ist dass die ukraine diesen krieg
gewinnen und die das treffen morgen mit
den g 7 finanzminister der wird über
einen preis deckel auch das ist nun
etwas völlig anderes über russisches öl
gesprochen ein bekannter gedanke schon
aus ellmau was empfehlen sie den
finanzministern der g7 für dieses
treffen morgen sind sie für eine
preisliche deckelung auch des russischen
öls
ja ich halte sowohl die deckelung des
russischen gases hier in europa das nur
nach europa fließen kann weil es in der
pipeline gebunden ist aber auch eine
internationale globale deckelung des
russischen öls das über schiffe weltweit
verkauft werden kann für richtig in der
tat wir haben in ellmau angefangen
diesen gedanken zu entwickeln bei dem g7
treffen und er funktioniert
insofern als dass wir diese wochen und
monate jetzt genutzt haben andere länder
zu überzeugen mit uns zusammen zu sagen
wir zahlen nicht mehr als diese
bestimmte summe für russisches öl und
damit auch druck auf putin auszuüben und
dafür zu sorgen dass er seine
kriegskasse nicht mehr erfüllen kann
auch die chinesen profonda
nicht alle sind an bord ist aber
diejenigen die
versuchen diesen preis zu unterlaufen
werden schiffe brauchen und sie werden
versicherungen brauchen und beides ohne
das kann man das öl nicht transportieren
beides ist weitgehend in der hand der
länder die mitmachen okay das war eine
indirekte antwort auf die frage und ich
danke nach brüssel vielen dank für
dieses gespräch
kranke frau illner und damit sind wir
wieder in der runde interessant preis
decke für russisches öl preis deckel für
russisches gas und besonders interessant
wie sehr sich europa einsetzt die
europäische kommission ursula von der
leyen dafür einsetzt dass über gewinne
abgeschöpft werden können um diese
preise zu normalisieren jetzt sehe ich
schon dass frau lang nicht interessant
ist zu hören was herr dazu sagt wir
haben einen interessanten massiven
europäischen impuls in diesen strommarkt
eben hineinzuregieren der bundeskanzler
hat das in meseberg sogar gesagt dass
all seine minister und premier kollegen
der gleichen auffassung sind dass sich
an diese regel des deutschen
strommarktes des europäischen
strommarktes dringend etwas verändern
muss ganz kurz die haltung der fdp dazu
hätte über das vorhaben schöpfen ja
gerne freuen wir haben vorhin über
entlassung gesprochen jetzt kommen wir
zu des pudels kern nämlich zu den
gigantischen strompreisen die sich
niemand mehr leisten kann die sich
verzwanzigfacht in den letzten wochen
und das kann kein unternehmen und kein
privater haushalt stellen und auch der
bundeshaushalt nicht ausgleichen
deswegen sind da wiederum zwei
mechanismen richtig und wichtig der
erste über den sprach die
kommissionspräsidentin frau von der
leyen gerade eben nämlich dass
strommarkt design das funktioniert so
nicht mehr bei der das hohe und teure
gas alles bestimmt und dadurch an extra
renditen war den anderen entstehen und
innerhalb genau dieses strommarktes zu
einer neuen regelung zu kommen ich würde
mich freuen wenn die europäische
kommission die eu das sehr schnell
schafft gegebenenfalls müssten was auch
national machen aber das natürlich was
ganz anderes als das leben gerade
geradeaus sagt marita christlicher über
gewinne gibt weil es genau weil die
begriffe etwas durch einen laufen ist
natürlich keine steuerrechtlichen
gewinne sondern es sind schlicht absurd
hohe preise aufgrund der möglichen
rahmenbedingungen wo ich sehr dafür wäre
es innerhalb des strommarktes genau das
zu ändern ist nicht der strompreis
insgesamt sinkt durch ein neues
sogenanntes mag die sein wenn das die eu
schnell schafft wäre es gut ansonsten
müssten wir den nationalrat wir kennen
ein solches instrument schon aus der
vergangenheit in deutschland wir hatten
mal haben noch die eeg-umlage er
abgeschafft worden zum ersten juli da
haben die stromkunden die erneuerbaren
energien sozusagen finanziert jetzt
müssten die erneuerbaren die
konventionellen sozusagen die
stromkunden mitfinanzieren das wäre so
eine art negatives egt bei das muss man
realismus am ende funktionieren das ist
nicht einfach hat frau von der leyen
zurecht beschrieben wie gesagt
europäische lösung wären gut ansonsten
eine nationale und gleich im anschluss
für das nicht verlängern müssen wir auch
noch über die strommenge reden denn die
ist eben auch preis bestimmt und auch
das angebot muss ausgeweitet werden weil
wir haben von allah weise nicht
untergehen ich versuche es nicht normal
hätte ich wollte ihnen gerne anbieten
dass sie etwas zum abschöpfen diese über
gewinne sagen können die eben keine über
gewinn steuer werden muss sondern eben
ein abschleppvorgang werden könnte ich
mache hier ganz schnell die runde weil
es wichtig ist ihre haltung dazu einmal
noch nach düsseldorf zu dem sozial und
arbeitsminister was sagen sie ja gut
also ist also wenn wir viele jahrzehnte
mit der jetzigen preis systematik bei
der energie gut gefahren sind und wir
jetzt sehen dass in dieser
krisensituation der mechanismus zu
situationen für die wir nicht ertragen
wollen und auch nicht mehr fair sind da
muss man das system anpassen und ich
fand dass das was frau ursula von der
leyen gesagt hat doch eine relativ
schlüssige idee es muss ja nicht sofort
eine steuer sein wir haben eine
situation dass
einfach die die kleine gasmenge dich
dazu führen darf dass wir strom mäßig
auch durch die decke lenz fähig sind
kuren deswegen ist eine eine veränderung
des mechanismus es was natürlich dann
auch dazu führt dass zum beispiel
regenerative nicht mehr ganz so viel
geld kriegen wie sie kriegen klar ja im
gesamtinteresse richtig und richtig sind
ricarda lang wichtige frage auch an die
grünen diese regelung hätte es schon ein
bisschen früher geben können sie deshalb
nicht früher gekommen auch von deutscher
seite nicht früher gekommen weil man
eben nicht wollte dass die öko strom
weniger gewinn machen und haben wir
jetzt diese situation damit es möglichst
ja also würden sich ökostrom auch damit
abfinden ihren gewinn hergeben zu müssen
na ja wir reden hier bei exorbitante
gewinne im reden nicht über normale
gewinnen die reinvestiert werden würde
was wichtig ist wenn wir reden über
gewinne die so hoch sind dass selbst
unternehmen niemals damit gerechnet
haben und ich glaube nicht dass das
argument dagegen die erneuerbaren
energien waren denn ich war in der
ersten person die sich für eine über
gewinn steuer eingesetzt hat und ich
muss sagen wir es jetzt nicht besonders
wichtig über den weg einer stabilen weg
des abschöpfen sondern was wichtig ist
dass wir jetzt an diese über gewinne
herangehen das ist ja niemand mehr
vermittelbar dass während manche
unglaublich harte zeiten haben jetzt mit
blick auf diesen winter natürlich
menschen mit wenig geld aber zum
beispiel auch kleine unternehmen ich
denke an handwerksbetriebe ich denke ein
bäckereien die gerade wirklich
existenznöte haben das gleichzeitig
einzelne konzerne riesige gewinne machen
verdient daher ist nicht erklärbar und
deshalb nehmen wir jetzt diese gewinne
und zu bezahlen damit entlastung für
kleinunternehmen für menschen mit wenig
geld dass es dann vielleicht ein
bisschen winter der solidarität statt
winter der mut diesen
dieser strommarkt preis ist natürlich
ein völlig irre jetzt verzwanzigfacht
verachtfacht hat sich wenigstens auf 14
fach der gaspreis
denken sie in diesen dimensionen auch
das den
dass solidarität eben auch mit
unternehmen die jetzt in eine echte
krise kommen notwendig ist also das ist
wichtig ist eben auch eine industrielle
basis jetzt habe ich meine frage eine
industrielle basis ist natürlich in
diesem land zu erhalten und von diesem
drama strompreisen runterzukommen
natürlich ich glaube das ist nur
entscheiden dass wir das große ganze in
den blick nehmen und nur herr lang
meinte gerade fälschlicherweise man sei
bisher gut gefahren mit dem energiemarkt
das stimmt natürlich überhaupt nicht wie
haben eine klimakrise
der dir leben wir live das muss man
niemandem erklären dar ein
genaues datum zu beleuchten ich sag ich
habe dich arbeiten ich hatte schon
betonte 30 millionen menschen in diesem
augenblick allein in pakistan 30
milliarden wurden aufgewandt an
staatsgeldern für die flut das erinnern
wir dass es wenige jahre her also
natürlich ist mir nicht gut damit
gefahren immer das große ganze im blick
nimmt open hat uns vor allem so
wahnsinnig er wohne rabl auch politisch
gemacht im sinne der energie krise die
wir jetzt haben
das heißt es geht ja nicht nur darum zu
sagen wie lösen wir das gerade spontan
wie sorgen wir dafür dass jetzt
entlastung stattfinden das ist total
wichtig das muss auch unternehmen
treffen die der sprache sondern es geht
eben darum gleichzeitig darauf
hinzuwirken dass wir sie enter werden
und ich bin da auch jeder diskussion
wird ja doch nicht mehr meinte wir
können noch innovativer werden und
verkehr sagt als wir das so ein spiel
wie wir so ein bisschen klimaschutz
rummachen es geht wirklich darum dafür
zu sorgen dass wir rauskommen aus dieser
zeit in der eine krise die andere
überschwemmt in der menschen über- als
gefühl haben man kann doch keine luft
mehr richtig zum atmen das kommt von
allen seiten und da braucht es natürlich
eine transformation loslegen und eine
regierung sagt wir haben planen da hilft
heute aber der hilft eben auch für
morgen und übermorgen dieses heute ist
er tatsächlich hässlicher zu malen als
das übermorgen und überübermorgen weil
wir heute zurück müssen zu kohle weil
wir heute vielleicht zurück müssen zu
atom weil wir heute diese lng terminals
anmieten wie groß ist ihre sorge dass
aus diesem provisorien dann doch wieder
ein größeres feld wird das wir nutzen um
unsere energie fragen zu lösen die sorge
ist riesig es jetzt nicht mein privat
problem sondern wir leben ja alle auf
dieser welt und wir leben auch alle von
einer welt die zunehmend von diesen
klimakatastrophen von einem klima chaos
gefasst wird und nur um das einmal so
plastisch zu machen die flut ist ein
extremwert ereignis gewesen was in
wenigen jahrzehnten in deutschland wie
alle paar wochen und monate auftreten
kann wenn es so weitergeht wenn wir
nicht intervenieren das sind ganz
konkrete
katastrophen die auch hier übrigens
wirtschaft und wohlstand und all das in
frage stellen also kurzum ja wir müssen
jetzt weg kommt von diesem fossile
energien es ist aber nicht so als sei
das naturgesetz also es ist nicht so als
könnten marianne mann zu sein das machen
allen dieter wendel gebaute ton eines
kohlekraftwerkes angeschaltet das sind
ja entscheidung die getroffen werden und
auch wenn die energiebasis zu sichern
haben es ohne spritze ich jemand der
losrennt und fossile energien
verteidigten die terminals neue
gasfelder vorsichtiger und auch im
gleichen atemzug praktisch davor warnt
dass wir so eine fossile renaissance
haben die ja eigentlich selber baut und
dabei mit der siebziger jahre von den
grünen ist aber auch dabei keine frage
das ist das kommt auch station dabei
gibt es die alternative dass wir haben
die erneuerbaren das heißt nicht und ich
glaube das muss man feststellen dass
heißt nicht dass man nicht provisorisch
zum beispiel reden manche von
schwimmenden lng terminals die kann man
schnell auf und abbauen dass man
provision gebraucht das niveau wie sie
die energie dazu muss das aber gerade
passiert die realität die realität diese
energiepolitik ist gerade eine andere
und das sind verträge die gehen über
lange jahre das sind aufwendige
konstruktion das sind milliarden an
investitionen die im schlimmsten falle
dargestellten also im falle von kuwait
und knicks für nix hat sie
offensichtlich eben eine gegenteilige
katar entschuldigung nicht über eine
gegenteilige es ist eine grosse gefallen
tut wenn man im leben betonen möchte es
sind entscheidungen und was wir gerade
auch als team und bewegung machen als
wir mobilisieren auch dahin geht dass
wir sagen wir brauchen einen druck für
eine echte transformation des gerecht
die solidarisch und dies eben mal jetzt
ist aber das ganze paket unterwegs
gewesen und wir versuchen noch ein
bisschen zu ordnen und zu sagen
preisbildung von kurt beck wie
realistisch ist dass die europäische
kommission
auch den deutschen hilft diese utopische
preise wieder nach unten zu bekommen wie
realistisch ist dass das europa und
dieses problem löst also ich habe die
worte von frau von der leyen ewigem wohl
gehört genau und habe direkt gedacht das
funktioniert doch nie in dieser
europäischen union
und deshalb wird man sicherlich hier auf
eine nationale lösung kommen schon
allein um auch eine schnelle lösung zu
haben also ich bin echt normalerweise
wirklich dagegen unternehmen in der
substanz zu besteuern die sollen ihre in
ihren geschäften nachgehen können aber
wenn man eine so krasse lage hat sich
das da derartig über gewinne erzielt
werden dann geht das gar nicht anders
als wenn man jetzt eben auch wieder
darüber spricht die leute brauchen
signale und das muss auch so was wie ein
gefühl von gerechtigkeit entstehen
können dann muss man da ran und dann
wäre das das beste wenn sich die
regierung an diesem wochenende gleich
mit darauf einigen würde das ist das was
elena ja auch mit dem autopiloten
angedeutet hat nämlich dass man die
gewinne so abschöpft dass sie gar nicht
groß über das steuersystem nicht groß um
die staatskasse laufen sondern
eigentlich direkt bei den leuten
verbleiben dann wäre das auf jeden fall
eine sinnvolle maßnahme da würde ich
nicht auf europa wetten wollen so und
videos ist aber die gefahr dass man da
bei einem ähnlichen murks landet wie bei
dieser gasanlage
ja dann müsste man vielleicht sich
soviel sofern sich so viel zeit nehmen
dass die dinge in einem ministerium
geprüft werden bevor man damit raus geht
also erstmal den klaren willen
formuliert dass man das möchte und
normalerweise ist politisch auch ein
einweg wo ein wille ist und dann müsste
man den ministerium entsprechend zeit
geben dass sie es aus arbeiten können
bei der gas umlage war das ja so da
wollte man diesen überraschungseffekt
erzielen und hatte die pläne noch gar
nicht so richtig ausgearbeitet dann wärs
doch vielleicht klüger den leuten zu
sagen dass es unser erklärtes ziel und
wir gehen davon aus dass wir in zwei
oder drei wochen die länder dann
rutschen dann auch fertig vorliegen
haben also einfach mal das pferd von
vorne und von hinten auf zeugen wir sind
bei der frage was es übergang und wo ist
die zukunft verlagern auch an sie die
frage wir brauchen jetzt akut und ganz
praktisch
mehr energie uns fehlt ja strom und uns
fehlt gas und deshalb gehen die preise
durch die decke wir haben diesen befund
auch schon vor dem krieg in der ukraine
gehabt aber jetzt ist er mit diesem
krieg natürlich noch viel massive im
raum wie weit gehen wir wie weit muss
man gehen die union sagt ganz klar atom
unbedingt wieder möglich machen kohle
wieder möglich machen wie sieht aber von
unionsseite also oppositionsseite auch
luisa neubauer aus für die erneuerbaren
zu streiten also erst einmal ist es ja
so dass wir in der union
einen massiven ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wurden und es hat ja in der
vergangenheit nicht daran gelegen dass
hier keine investition für neuer waren
energien haben sondern es war ja so dass
die vorlagen dass sie das die vorgaben
so waren dass eine baugenehmigung einer
windkraftanlage
wenigstens zwei bis drei jahre dauerte
weil man die kita zions perioden
ausschreiben musste
ich wollte noch mal sagen ich komme aus
einer religion im münsterland wohnung wo
die meisten mit kraft in nordrhein
westfalen steht ja nie probleme unsere
bürgerwindpark finanziert zu bekommen
es ist jetzt gut dass das planungsrecht
verändert worden ist da haben viele sein
wenn auch die grünen ja wir haben auch
in nordrhein westfalen jetzt die ganzen
verordnungen im kabinett gehabt und
tragen den rest der verordnung nächster
woche im kabinett um auch bei uns die
gebiete entwicklungspläne dieser politik
anzupassen dass die regenerativen sehr
viel mehr platz bekommen das ist dann
daraus gebaut werden können und das wird
jetzt hoffe ich mit den neuen
planungsrecht auch viel schneller gehen
was die windkraft angeht und was auch
die photovoltaik an die da aber war
photovoltaik allerdings so zahlt ein
problem versuchen sie mal zurzeit an
handwerker zu kriegen der ihnen eine
photovoltaik anlage auf ihr dach
montiert da haben wir ganz einfache
probleme dass wir die leute nicht haben
die diese anlagen zurzeit montieren und
machen wir finden auch gewisse teile
dass man sie nicht in betrieb nehmen
können aber das wird man ja alles
irgendwie in den griff kriegen so aber
jetzt für diese übergangszeit
man muss auch sehen alle kalkulationen
energiepolitik waren was sind eigentlich
die die überbrückungs energie ein
bisschen bei den regenerativen so weit
sind und da haben sie sehr stark da
haben wir sehr stark auf gras gesetzt
wir können nicht mehr auf gas setzen
weil wir die auseinandersetzung in
europa haben die wir nummer haben und
deswegen glaube ich schon dass man
akzeptieren muss dass wir für diese
brücke jetzt auch wieder andere energien
einsetzen da ist natürlich klar dass wir
kohle kraftwerke länger laufen lassen
können wie wir das in ausstiegsplänen
vorhatten aber ich kenne in deutschland
niemand der aus den grundsatz aus der
kohle zu stellen auch aus der braunkohle
auszuschalten wer davon weg will aber es
geht jetzt darum dieses tempo langsamer
zu machen um mehr energie zu haben hatte
sie haben meine meinung ist auch
eindeutig dass auch die drei
atomkraftwerke die wir haben sie weiter
zu betreiben für diese eng begrenzte
übungszeit moralisch vertretbar ist das
ist keine rolle wie wird's in der
atompolitik sondern ich glaube jetzt
eine möglichkeit dar über die atomkraft
haben fünf bis sechs prozent vor den
strom machen den wir brauchen damit
könnten wir in erheblichem umfange
gaskraftwerke stilllegen in dieser
situation ich glaube es wäre gut wenn es
technisch vernünftig ist es zu tun er
wird keinen einzigen kubikmeter gas
dürfe man verstromen haben sie auch noch
im juli gesagt jetzt wird deutscher
strom aus gas nach frankreich verkauft
ich frage sie nicht ob das gut ist die
franzosen brauchen das sehr dringend
aber wann fängt das deutsche nationale
interesse an ist eine fachfrage an den
fdp-politiker na ja wir reden ja dieser
tage insbesondere auch von europäischer
solidarität insbesondere beim gas und
deswegen zwei dinge frau illner erstens
wir müssen insgesamt schneller werden
ich war ganz überrascht über die worte
von herrn laumann gerade der gesagt hat
ja wir wollten immer irgendwas nicht
geklappt bei den erneuerbaren das
planungsrecht in deutschland ist eine
einzige katastrophe gewesen dass ich
total bürokratisch und mit verlaub die
ampel koalition keine unionsgeführte
bundesregierung wie als ampelkoalition
haben jetzt die planungs beschleunigung
auf den weg gebracht das ein erfolg da
wären wir auch weitermachen das ist erst
das zweite ist das können wir jetzt sehr
kurzfristig tun sehr kurzfristig sollten
wir die mengen ausweiten um den preis
ganz deutlich zu dämpfen deswegen
schlagen wir vor da müssen wir in der
koalition darüber reden erwarten jetzt
auch den stresstest ab die drei am netz
befindlichen kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen
zu lassen ich komme ja aus niedersachsen
das kernkraftwerk im emsland
beispielsweise ist eines der
effizientesten der welt und deswegen ist
unser vorschlag genau das zu tun dass in
die kurzfristigen maßnahmen das auch
keine renaissance der kernenergie an der
stelle sondern das was wir kurzfristig
tun müssen leider auch bei der
braunkohle bei der steinkohle das sind
alles keine wunschprojekte der ampel und
mittel- und
sich natürlich der deutliche ausbau der
erneuerbaren die dann auch stetiger
werden müssen auch mit speichern
versehen werden müssen und da ist das
planungsrecht der schlüssel so lang wir
sind bei der frage wie sehr wird die
werden die grünen unter diese unter
einem glaubwürdigkeitsverlust leiden
wenn allen die dinge die sie eigentlich
ganz schnell überwinden wollten jetzt
doch für 243 für vier jahre zwingend
gebraucht werden weil wir in einer
nationalen internationalen groß krise
sind ich muss ein punkt schon noch mal
vorweg schieben warum wir gerade so
massiv strom an frankreich exportieren
das war in frankreich die atomkraftwerke
versagen wir sehen doch regale der treue
risikoreich und die atomkraft zu staaten
zu schaden kommt weil dort ein großteil
der meiler überhaupt nicht mehr ans netz
gehen kann das heißt unsere hohe
strompreis hängt gerade auch mit dem
scheitern der atomkraft zusammen ich
glaube es muss man diese ganzen preis
debatte schon ehrlich mit sagen und ich
glaube dass wir als grüne dann stark
durch diese position gehen wenn man es
erstens abnimmt dass wir kurzfristig
schwierige schritte gehen aber
langfristig das ziel 100 prozent
erneuerbare energien nicht aus den augen
verlieren und wenn wir vor allem anhand
der realität argumentieren und nicht
anhand von was könnte es jetzt gerade
eine debatte dass erleichterungen geben
und deshalb wenn es um die atomkraft
geht dann werden uns das
stresstestergebnis anschauen und
entscheiden tut man dann wenn man
ergebnis vorliegen hat und das ist noch
nicht der fall und wir müssen an dieser
stelle leider einen punkt machen
und haben eine ganz praktische aufgabe
vor uns und wahrscheinlich noch ganz
viele große zukunftsfragen aufzuklären
aber jetzt in dieser situation erst
einmal eine mega krise allerletzte frage
frau kurt beck würden sie denken dass
wir das tatsächlich in einem jahr schon
hinter uns haben oder nehmen wir über
einen zeitraum von drei wir reden was
sozusagen die akute krisensituation
angeht sicherlich über zwei winter weil
man vorher das was man jetzt auch
schnell an
erneuerbaren schaffen möchte und was man
eben auch die lng terminals werden ja
nicht in lichtgeschwindigkeit gebaut
sondern sie brauchen dann doch
tatsächlich
mindestens ein jahr eventuell kommen in
diesem winter die ersten gaslieferungen
darüber an also man muss ich auf jeden
fall noch zwei jahre einstellen und dann
kann man nur hoffen dass das was die
bundesregierung auch angeschoben hat und
was vielleicht auch tatsächlich mal
positiv zu vermelden ist nämlich zu
versuchen grünen wasserstoff aus kanada
zu kriegen dass da dann die industrie
allerdings genug alternativen dass das
zumindest beginnt ja ganz schnell team
aktiv